gracias por continuar en la pantalla de
france 24 estamos de regreso para
conocer las principales noticias de
materia económica de américa latina y
del resto del mundo y nos acompaña por
supuesto jorge hurtado jorge muy buenas
noches vamos a comenzar hablando de las
remesas a nivel global así es bueno las
remesas crecerán en los países de
ingresos medios y bajos más de lo que se
esperaba en 2021 y latinoamérica y el
caribe llegará a un nuevo récord
convirtiéndose en la región con más
incremento en todo el mundo aquí las
remesas a santiago crecerán un 21 6%
para fin de año un nuevo máximo de 126
mil millones de dólares para los países
de ingreso bajo y medio las remesas
ascenderán un 7,3 por ciento a 589 mil
millones de dólares detrás de
latinoamérica las regiones que más
remesas recibirán son oriente medio y
norte de áfrica con un aumento del 9,7
por ciento respecto a 2020 por su parte
asia meridional un 8% áfrica al sur del
sahara 11,2 presidente europa y asia
central un 53 por ciento para el próximo
año el banco mundial espera que las
remesas aumenten un 2,6 por ciento a
nivel mundial con 4-4 en latinoamérica
esto debido a las perspectivas de menor
crecimiento de estados unidos que es el
país donde más remesas se emiten hacia
esta región del total de remesas
enviadas este año méxico fue el
principal receptor con 52 mil 700
millones de dólares equivalentes al 42
por ciento de las remesas para la región
para algunos países con economías más
pequeñas el valor de las remesas
representa más del 20 por ciento del
producto interno bruto por ejemplo
santiago el salvador ahí la remesa
representan el 26,2 por ciento en
honduras otro 26,6 por ciento y
guatemala un 18 por ciento según el
organismo los efectos adversos del cobi
19 y los daños causados por los
huracanes grave e ira también
contribuyeron a un aumento de los flujos
de las remesas hacia méxico y sobre todo
centroamérica porque vamos ahora a reino
unido que está registrando su nivel de
inflación más alto en una década verdad
así es ahí el dato es de 4,2 por ciento
interanual en octubre es un nivel más
alto desde noviembre de 2011 cuando se
sitúen 48 luego de una leve caída en
septiembre el índice de inflación volvió
a subir empujado por un aumento la
energía para los hogares los vehículos
de segunda mano o el combustible según
la oficina nacional de estadísticas y
aunque el banco central de reino unido
se ha mostrado preocupado por este
incremento de la inflación durante su
última reunión en noviembre no ajustaron
su política de tasas de interés que se
encuentra en el nivel históricamente más
bajo del 0.1 por ciento en busca de
impulsar la economía por esta cifra que
ya superó las expectativas de
crecimiento para algunos economistas
podría impulsar los a replantearse la
tasa de interés el próximo mes cuando
les toca reunirse nuevamente la decisión
del banco central del reino unido- ese
mirar a la que después viven otros
bancos de ese continente que se debaten
entre enfrentar la inflación sin afectar
un crecimiento económico que de por sí
ya está debilitado por la pandemia todo
un gran desafío sin lugar a dudas jorge
bueno este jueves se van a reunir los
representes y representantes de eeuu de
méxico y de ganar un encuentro muy
esperado contános que se va a debatir en
materia económica ha sido bueno esta es
la primera reunión que se da en cinco
años y se busca promover la integración
económica de américa del norte la cumbre
de santiago es conocida como la cumbre
de los tres amigos uno de los temas
centrales sin duda serán los créditos
fiscales para vehículos eléctricos que
favorecería a los fabricantes
sindicalizados con sede en eeuu
eeuu que es el mayor socio comercial de
méxico y canadá y los automóviles y
camiones son los productos
manufacturados más comercializados entre
estos tres países canadá y méxico por su
parte buscan igualdad de condiciones en
los últimos años méxico y canadá también
compiten por atraer a empresas para que
instalen sus plantas de la cadena de
suministro de vehículos eléctricos en
sus países mientras que eeuu busca
proveedores alternativos de china sobre
estos materiales para fabricar baterías
de vehículos eléctricos el proyecto de
ley sobre el gasto social y el clima que
se estudia en el congreso incluye hasta
12 mil 500 dólares en créditos fiscales
para los vehículos eléctricos fabricados
en eeuu en la cumbre también se debate
temas como seguridad migración el
cohetes y 9 cualquier que dicen los
indicadores de la jornada bueno
arrancamos con walker que cerró en rojo
por los resultados trimestrales de
algunas empresas importantes del sector
minorista y los efectos del aumento de
la inflación
europa la bolsa cerraron mixtas por los
informes empresariales y en américa
latina la bolsa de sao paulo retrocedió
tras el recorte de la previsión de
crecimiento del producto interno bruto
de ese país finalizamos como siempre con
la tan esperada cifra del día cuál es
hoy la cifra de 139 mil 600 millones de
dólares el valor de mercado de rivia en
el nuevo test la de la bolsa de valores
que ya supera a volkswagen aunque vende
pocos vehículos gracias jorge por esta
completísima crónica económica a nuestra
audiencia como siempre le invitamos a
continuar informando se en france 24 y
en france 24 punto com sigan con
nosotros
[Música]